C
INCLING PLACES LI THE
PANAMA CAN ALO WITH MA
OTRS.
IT WITHHE BAK AND REPORT
ALL  THIS WHO'S BEE FOLLOWING
THE STORY FR THEET-GO OUOWN SARA
PORT WITH ANPDAT FROM
LA WEEK
ABSOLUTELY YOARE I MONNA
SHE VE IN GREAT FAL AND I
DRE ALL T WAYERE TO
MONTAN NEX TO THE AIR FOE
BASE.
AND ST T GIVE Y THE GRAVITY
OF THE SITTIONND HOW
DAEROUS TS IS AND WHTHE
U.S. COMMEE DEPARENTS
SSIB INVESTITINGLONG
WITHHE FBI AIRORCE BE
INTAS 150 INTERN,
INRCONTINENTAL BLIST
ABLE TO PASS  SOMOF THE
LOS.
YOUAN SEE THEM FM THROAD.
TH PROBLEM IS SEAN AT T
IN TS ARE AREITERALLY OUT
HONING INN TH TECHNOLIES.
HUAW TECHNOLIES HAVE AESS
TO TSE TELECOMMUNITION
DEVIS AN THE FEAR IS TH THE
CHINESE GERNMT.
SO SPOKE WITH CONESSM NAT
ROSEALE EARLIERODAY ANDHIS
IS WT HEAD TOAY.>>E ARHERENONTA.
WE KNO NOWHAT THE COMRCE
DEPAMENT AS WELL A THE FBI
BELIEVE THA THE IS ONGOING
INVESTATIOIGHT NOW IT'S A
HUAWEI TECHNOLOGS NEARHE
AIR FORCE BASND IT IS RIGHNE OU.
WHAT IS YOURIGGE CONCERN
RIGHT NOW
>> IERY CONRNEDE GOES
CK TO THE MONITING.
IFHEYAN PK LITTLEIECESOF DATA AE
VEMES, WHERE THOSEOMEN
ARE ING?
E IS TAKINGLACE
ANTHAT GIVES THEA VE B
VANTAGE OVER O OWNILITY.
SO WHAVE AN ARSAL OFCBMs
ESPECIALIGHT NE SEE ALLT
THEHAOS HASAKENLACE AROUND
THE WLD.
>> A WHADO WE DO NOW?
>> TS IWHAT I WAS SAYIN
EAIER THATT'S ALWAYS EASIETO PRM
TAKI PLACE BT TONWIND
TH.
TOOTHPASTE BAC IN E TUBE ONCE
IT'S OUT.
D THA ISERY DIFFICULT.
YOU CANVENTUALLY CLEING
ESEP TO OUR CYBERSECURITY
SYSTS A THE TYPE O WOR
T IT A LOT ME EXPENVE
AND IT MUC MOR DIFFICUBECAUSE UY
MISSEDNTILT REARS ITSGLY
HEAD AND WE VE A PROBL THA
SHS UP.
I THINKHAT WEEEDO AGASTART FR B.
WENOW WE A RIG NOW IT'S GOUT ANY
A ME THAT EQUMENTROM
THEELL TOWERS OVETHE NEXT0
DAYSHE CNESE COMMENTS RTY
HAS PROBLEMITH THAT IS A
LAN TERM THAT W USEROUND
HE QUI OFTENWE TELL TM THAT WE E
AT OUR COUNTRYS SECUR.
>> SEAN CONESSM ALONG WITOKLAHOS
IN LAWMAKE FROM
SHINGTON, D.C.ARE SAYIN
THAT THISS THEIRBILI TO
PUSHHEM OUT RHT N T GET
EM AND THE CHISE GERNMENT
MOVE OUOF O TLICH
MEDITION
TH ONLY REASON TY BE ABLE
TO DO TT I BECAU UND THE
DONA TRUMPDMINTRATION THEY
BEEN ABLE  EXPDHE
ILITIESHE PKS DEPARTMENT
TO INVESTITE AWELL AS TFBAS WL E